c'est un truc de fou est-ce que vous
avez vu cette intelligence artificielle
qui va tout faire à votre place c'est
chat j'ai pété c'est développé par open
Nike est une société qui appartient
notamment à Elon Musk regarder les
usages sont dingues par exemple je vais
lui demander rédige un communiqué de
presse pour le lancement de l'iPhone 14
le groupe Apple pire vous annoncer le
lancement de l'iPhone 14 les modèles des
smartphones disponible et il y a tout en
fait c'est un vrai communiqué de presse
comme c'est un journaliste qui l'avait
écrit écrit une rédaction sur la Seconde
Guerre mondiale la Seconde Guerre
mondiale était l'un des conflits les
plus dévastateur de l'histoire de
l'humanité elle a impliqué la plupart
des nations du monde y compris enfin
bref si vous êtes à l'école il vous fait
votre truc quoi alors attention il y a
quand même des fautes donc on y va avec
parcimonie d'autant plus que c'est Unia
mais qu'elle ne sait pas tout écrit un
poème sur les caméras de Sony à la
manière de Charles Baudelaire ouais oh
cameras Sony instrument de notre art
avec vous nous captons l'éphémères et
figeons l'instant ouais c'est du
Baudelaire sans réellement être du
Baudelaire et ça montre là où on
pourrait aller à l'avenir et vraiment
chambouler la face du monde on en parle
sur Youtube très bientôt